[Música]
estas son las noticias de france 24 los
27 países integrantes de la unión
europea a través de sus embajadores en
bruselas aprobaron el texto del acuerdo
alcanzado entre este bloque y el reino
unido- para su relación comercial en la
era post bereshit ahora resta la
aprobación por parte del parlamento
europeo y también del gobierno británico
tenemos detalles en minutos
después de varios días de disputas y
también de la negativa del presidente de
eeuu donald trump el mandatario dio su
brazo a torcer y firmó el plan de ayuda
económica que desembolsar a 900.000
millones de dólares a los ciudadanos más
afectados por la pandemia del cob en 19
y siguen avanzando rápidamente los
planes de vacunación contra el
coronavirus en américa latina méxico
recibió su segundo lote de vacunas de la
farmacéutica pfiezer by antec mientras
que argentina pondrá en marcha su plan
de inoculación con la vacuna rusa
sputnik beach también ofrecieron desde
buenos aires ayuda a países como bolivia
y uruguay
muy buenos días bienvenidos a este
informativo de france 24 soy santiago
lópez gonzález vamos a comenzar en
bruselas allí los 27 países de la unión
europea aprobaron a través de sus
embajadores allí en la capital belga la
puesta en marcha de manera provisional
del acuerdo comercial de la era post
bereshit entre este bloque de países y
el reino unido- dicho plan debería
entrar en vigor a partir del primero de
enero del 2021
ahora este texto legal debe pasar a
manos del parlamento europeo y también
del gobierno británico para recibir el
visto bueno el parlamento europeo ha
indicado que es demasiado tarde para
celebrar una sesión de votación de
emergencia antes de que finalice el
periodo de transición el próximo 31 de
diciembre vamos a conocer más detalles
con luisa pulido en la ciudad de londres
luisa muy buenas tardes un paso más pero
como ya lo decíamos restan varias etapas
en este largo proceso de aprobación hay
un avance por lo menos del lado de la
unión europea que resta entonces allí en
este proceso del lado del reino unido-
buenas tardes un paso importante y
necesario para empezar a establecer esta
nueva relación entre el reino unido y
europa posiblemente menos conflictiva y
también abrir las puertas para este
acuerdo comercial el parlamento
británico ha sido convocado para este 30
de diciembre para votar el acuerdo el
acuerdo de la nueva relación y el
acuerdo comerciales será una votación
que se prevé sencilla el primer ministro
tiene las mayorías el jefe de la
oposición si quiere estar me ha dicho
que no está de acuerdo con todos los
términos de este acuerdo pero lo más
razonable para salvar la economía y
salir sin acuerdo es apoyarlo pero el
scottish national party ha dicho que no
lo apoyará porque básicamente este
partido lo que quiere seguir en su
relación con la unión europea sin
embargo se prevé que será una votación
sencilla el primer ministro debe
convencer todavía a los euroescépticos
de su partido de que este es el mejor
acuerdo posible entre tanto el jefe del
gabinete británico michael gov ha dicho
que las empresas y las
deben prepararse por posibles efectos
que pueden tener a partir del primero de
enero como no tendrán que hacer tendrían
que hacer una fila diferente en los
aeropuertos y podrían tener cargos en
los servicios de rubén pues el 30 de
diciembre entonces sabremos la respuesta
del lado británico muchas gracias luisa
por este reporte desde la ciudad de
londres avanzamos con otros temas debido
a problemas de carga y envío la dupla
facer variante que ha [__] la
entrega de miles de dosis de la vacuna
contra el cob y 19 afectando así el plan
de vacunación de 8 países europeos los
inconvenientes logísticos tienen lugar
en la planta en la localidad de poor's
en bélgica lo que ha llevado a que los
gobiernos de estos 8 países hayan tenido
que suspender por espacio de algunas
horas o tal vez días este avance de la
inoculación masiva como medida temporal
de otra parte la comisión europea indicó
que la entrega de las primeras 200
millones de dosis adquiridas por el
bloque de los 27 finalizará en
septiembre del 2021
asimismo la farmacéutica astrazéneca
afirmó
con su vacuna una efectividad del 100
por ciento en los casos más graves
vamos a cruzar el atlántico nos vamos
hasta eeuu el presidente de ese país
donald trump dio su brazo a torcer tras
varios días bloqueando la aprobación de
un plan de estímulo económico para los
afectados por la pandemia del cob y 19 y
también después de varias disputas al
interior de la casa blanca y el congreso
el mandatario aprobó desembolsar 900 mil
millones de dólares que serán otorgados
a los ciudadanos más afectados
sebastián espinoza nos cuenta más
donald trump da marcha atrás después de
bloquear durante varios días el proyecto
de ley de estímulos por 900.000 millones
de dólares acordado por republicanos y
demócratas en el congreso el presidente
saliente firmó sorpresivamente la
iniciativa el domingo en la noche como
presidente de eeuu en mi responsabilidad
de proteger a la gente en nuestro país
de la devastación y las dificultades
causadas por el virus chino sin embargo
por la inacción de camps cerca de 14
millones de estadounidenses perdieron
las ayudas por desempleo ya que
expiraron el domingo para no firmar su
amistad en que los 600 dólares de ayudas
para los ciudadanos afectados por la
pandemia no eran suficientes
un argumento sorpresivo ya que los
mismos republicanos eran los que se
oponían a que se aumentara la ayuda de
berna créanlo o no los demócratas están
de acuerdo con el presidente 600 dólares
no son suficientes para los individuos
que la han pasado mal durante los
últimos siete meses y no son suficientes
para darle un impulso a las necesidades
de nuestra economía el mandatario
aseguró que a pesar de que se firmó el
proyecto de ley todavía espera que el
congreso apruebe un cambio en el
subsidio al aumentar lo de 600 a 2.000
dólares el proyecto de ley incluye miles
de millones de dólares para ayudar a los
estados con la distribución de vacunas
un programa de préstamos para pequeñas
empresas además de un presupuesto para
mantener al gobierno financiado durante
el resto del año fiscal
y entretanto en américa latina' varios
países avanzan con sus respectivos
planes de vacunación contra el hobbit 19
esto después de recibir un nuevo lote de
vacunas de la dupla facer by and tech
méxico por ejemplo avanza en su plan de
inoculación nacional a partir de mañana
martes argentina también estima aplicar
unas 300.000 dosis de la vacuna rusa
sputnik vi al tiempo que ofreció desde
buenos aires extender su ayuda a países
como uruguay y bolivia andrés meza muñoz
nos cuenta más en el siguiente informe
en américa latina sólo méxico chile y
costa rica han comenzado a vacunar a sus
ciudadanos contra el kobe 19 méxico
continúa su programa enfocándose en
médicos enfermeros y soldados el país
recibió un segundo cargamento de 42 mil
900 dosis de las farmacéuticas pfizer y
bayonne tec y más de 34 mil se
destinarán la ciudad de mexico la más
golpeada por el virus es muy importante
dado que tenemos que proteger a los que
nos protegen y entonces estas personas
sobre todo los de primera línea están
muy en contacto con personas enfermas
entonces si ellos se enferman también
suceden dos cosas una pues pueden
transmitir la enfermedad
y la otra que no solo a los pacientes o
usuarios sino que a sus familias y la
otra tiene que ver con que ellos podrían
este dejar de ir a trabajar usted
tendríamos una disminución del sistema
de salud argentina por su parte empezará
la inoculación el martes tras haber
recibido el primer lote de 300.000 dosis
de la vacuna rusa sputnik el presidente
alberto fernández ofreció su ayuda a
otros países de la región para
garantizar la adquisición del antídoto
hablé con el canciller uruguayo mi amigo
pancho bustillo y hablé con el
presidente de bolivia luis arce les dije
que en lo que yo pudiera ayudar contaban
conmigo me puse a disposición para
ayudarlos y generar los contactos
necesarios para ayudarlos a tener la
vacuna en otras naciones
latinoamericanas como colombia y ecuador
esperan que las primeras dosis de la
vacuna de facer y bayonne tec lleguen a
sus territorios en enero mientras que en
brasil el presidente ya ir bolsonaro un
escéptico de la vacunación dice que no
se siente presionado para inocular a su
población
el veloz aumento de los contagios en
panamá particularmente en la capital y
en la provincia panamá oeste ha llevado
a que el gobierno instauró nuevamente la
medida del confinamiento que entrara en
vigor a partir del 4 de enero hasta el
14 del mismo mes regirá una estricta
cuarentena sólo será permitida las
compras esenciales por horario y género
en eeuu las autoridades confirmaron que
el autor de la explosión ocurrida el día
de navidad en la ciudad de nashville
falleció en ese ataque
los investigadores del fbi encontraron
en el lugar de la explosión varios
restos humanos que fueron cotejados con
muestras de adn que sirvieron para
identificar al sospechoso bajo el nombre
de anthony quinn warner de 63 años donde
basándonos en la evidencia que hemos
reunido hasta ahora hemos llegado a la
conclusión de que un individuo llamado
anthony warner es el atacante que estaba
presente cuando estalló la bomba y que
murió en la explosión pasamos esta
conclusión en evidencia forense incluida
la evidencia de adn de la que se
enteraran así como la evidencia que se
reunió en el lugar del atentado
esto en las noticias buen día para todos
[Música]